Mick Baron
If you imagine a three-dimensional forest, and you can actually literally fly through
the forest. Up through the surface canopy, midway, down through the bottom,
looking up into the canopy.
That's what it was like.
It was a beautiful experience for anybody.
These forests occupied massive areas of the east coast of [Tasmania].
In the, obviously, close in the coastal zone.
So these little forests were effectively, from my way of thinking, little
natural nurseries.
You couldn't put a net through them, you couldn't drive a boat through them because the surface
matting was so thick, but in under the forest, the fish life was, without doubt, far more
abundant than it is now.
There's no doubt about that.